[MUSIC PLAYING]
OLIVER WOODMAN: So
my name's Ollie.
This is Andrew.
It's great to see
so many of you here.
I know it's been a long day.
And today we're going to talk
to you about media playback
on Android using ExoPlayer.
In terms of what
we're going to cover,
we're really going to try and
cater a little bit for everyone
in this talk.
So what that means is
we're going to start
with some fundamentals.
So we're going to briefly
discuss what ExoPlayer is.
We're going to discuss
some of its features.
We're going to discuss a
little bit about when you
might want to use ExoPlayer.
And we're going to go
through a simple example that
shows how you might be
able to get started.
After that, perhaps more
for those who are already
familiar with
ExoPlayer, we're going
to run quite quickly through
some more advanced topics.
So we'll talk about
media composition, which
is a new feature ExoPlayer v2.
We'll talk about some of
the internals of ExoPlayer,
and we'll describe a little
bit about how they work
and how playback actually works.
And then finally we'll
build on that knowledge
and we'll start to talk about
how you can really customize
and fine tune ExoPlayer to do
a really good job of matching
your specific use case.
OK, so let's get started.
What is ExoPlayer?
So for those of you who
aren't familiar with ExoPlayer
already, it's a media
playback library for Android.
It works on Jelly
Bean and above,
and it's written in Java.
So as Android developers,
it's already in the language
that you're most familiar with.
If you want to ExoPlayer, you
include it as a dependency,
just as you would include
any other Java library.
And it's also open source.
So if you're
inspired to check out
our source code after this
talk, you can easily do that.
And the last slide
of this presentation
will actually have a link
to our GitHub repository.
In terms of features,
we have come a long way
since we initially open
sourced ExoPlayer, which
was back at Google I/O in 2014.
So in that initial
release, we supported
DASH and SmoothStreaming
adaptive media playbacks,
primarily using fragmented
MP4 as the container format.
We also supported TTML
captions and common encryption.
Not too long after
that we added support
for HLS and the MPEG-TS
container format,
and also some additional
caption formats.
And since then we've
really been quite busy,
adding support for loads
of more traditional media
formats like MP3, MP4, Ogg
and Matroska and so on.
We also others
several extensions.
What ExoPlayer
extensions are is a way
of bringing functionality from
other libraries into ExoPlayer.
So as a concrete example, if you
use OkHttp as your networking
stack for the rest
of your application,
you might actually want to
use that exact same networking
stack for media playbacks.
And you can do that with
OkHttp extension, which
allows you to use that exact
same network stack inside
of ExoPlayer.
So this brings us up to
the middle of last year.
And at this point we
kind of took a step back,
and we made some quite
in-depth architectural changes
inside the player.
And we released
ExoPlayer version 2.
In this release
we had the support
for more advanced features
like MultiPeriod DASH supports,
gapless audio, and
media composition,
which is something
we'll talk quite
a lot about in a little while.
At the same time we tried to
make ExoPlayer easier to use.
So we added Simple
ExoPlayer view--
sorry, Simple ExoPlayer, which
is a slightly higher level
API for using ExoPlayer,
and also some playback UI
components that
you can use to get
started really quickly
out of the box.
Since then we've been
adding more features.
Most notably we
recently added support
for variable speed playback.
And we've also been
building up our ability
to cache media as it's played.
And so this is where
we're at today.
And the key takeaway
from this slide
isn't necessarily that
you should understand
everything that's on it.
Probably for your
particular use case
you only need a very small
subset of these features.
The key takeaway here
is really that ExoPlayer
has kind of evolved into quite
a fully featured media library
now.
And so if you have a media
playback use case for Android,
probably ExoPlayer is going to
support what you want to do.
So now we know a bit
about the features there.
Let's talk about when it might
make sense to use ExoPlayer
and when it might makes sense
to use the obviously alternative
to ExoPlayer, which is Android's
built in MediaPlayer API.
So the first thing to
note is that MediaPlayer
works all the way back to
the beginning of Android.
ExoPlayer is Jelly
Bean and above only.
This is far less of an
issue than it used to be.
And in fact there's only around
2% of active Android devices
still on earlier
versions of Android.
But if you really care
a lot about providing
continued support to
that 2%, then MediaPlayer
is going to be your best bet.
In terms of what use cases
each of these solutions
is best suited for, MediaPlayer
does quite a good job
of simple use cases.
So if you just
have an MP3 that's
maybe bundled in
your APK and you
want to play it inside
your app, then MediaPlayer
is going to work
just fine for you.
Maybe you're already using it.
And there's no real reason
why you should switch.
Where ExoPlayer really
comes into its own
is for more advanced use
cases, so specifically
any kind of adaptive streaming,
including DASH, SmoothStreaming
and HLS, and use
cases where you really
want to leverage some
of the advanced features
that ExoPlayer provides, like
media composition and caching.
Another difference that's
worth bearing in mind
is the way that these two
APIs have been designed.
MediaPlayer is very
much a black box.
You don't get very much
control over the inner workings
of the player.
And in contrast, ExoPlayer
is designed really
to be very customizable
and extensible.
And you can really
dig in and start
to fine tune the various
dials inside of ExoPlayer
to get things working just
the way you want them to.
So ExoPlayer is really
best if you are probably
an advanced user and you want
to kind of tweak these things.
A final but important
consideration
is to consider the difference
of where the player actually
lives when using
MediaPlayer and ExoPlayer.
So when you use MediaPlayer, as
you can see on the left here,
the MediaPlayer
implementation is actually
in the Android operating system.
And the division here is the
horizontal line that you see.
So below is the operating system
and above is your application.
When you use ExoPlayer,
the actual player
implementation ships as
part of your application.
And it really just goes through
to some quite low level media
APIs in the platform,
mainly for providing access
to hardware decoders.
So why is this important?
Well one reason is that
Android's media power
has actually evolved over time.
So as a result of that,
the behavior that you get
may vary slightly from Android
release to Android release.
In contrast with ExoPlayer,
we have an advantage.
So you can ship a single
version of the player
inside your application.
And you're going to get
that exact same version
across all versions of Android.
And this means that
ExoPlayer is really
better positioned to provide
a very consistent experience.
Another important
benefit of this model
is when we add a new
feature, we can generally
support all the way back to
Jelly Bean with ExoPlayer,
whereas a new feature
in MediaPlayer
is only going to be available
for subsequent releases
of Android.
An interesting example
of these advantages
is actually variable
speed playback supports.
So this was supported in
MediaPlayer from Marshmallow.
And recently we added
support in ExoPlayer.
And because we didn't have any
dependencies on new low level
media APIs or anything
like that in the platform,
we were able to add support
all the way back to Jelly Bean.
What we discovered next
was that there was actually
a bug in the playback rate and
pitch adjustment implementation
that affected both
MediaPlayer and ExoPlayer.
And we were able to
fix that bug, again,
all the way back to Jelly
Bean with ExoPlayer,
and only in O and
later for MediaPlayer.
So at this point, hopefully you
can see some of the benefits
ExoPlayer has.
But you might be
thinking that you
would be more
confident in using it
if you knew that some people
were using it already.
And I'm happy to
say that we actually
use ExoPlayer very extensively
in Google's own applications.
So most notably YouTube,
which is obviously
a huge video streaming
service, and also
applications like Google Play
Movies and Google Photos.
And we've actually seen
really strong adoption
from the wider development
community as well.
So here are just some
of the applications
that for some use or
other use ExoPlayer today.
And it's not just
a handful either.
There are actually over 140,000
applications on the Play Store
today that are making
use of ExoPlayer.
If your app's one
of these, thank you
very much for your adoption.
And please keep
sending us feedback.
It's really important
to us and it actually
does guide a lot
of what we work on.
So next up we're going
to dive in some code
and show a simple example.
And for that I'm going to
hand you over to Andrew.
ANDREW LEWIS: Hi, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
So let's imagine you've
got an existing app
and you'd like to
add an MP4 player
to that app-- so just
showing a simple video
in your existing app.
I'm going to go through
the minimal changes
that you need to make
to use ExoPlayer.
So the first step is
going to be to add
a dependency on ExoPlayer And
there are two main options
here.
You can either bring in the
whole of the ExoPlayer library.
And that will include support
for adaptive streaming formats
like DASH and HLS.
And for that you can use this
line in your build.gradle file.
This is kind of the
kitchen sink option.
So the alternative is that
you can just pick and choose
the specific modules from
the ExoPlayer library
that you need.
So for this example, I'm
going to add a dependency
on the core library, which
contains the main player
obviously, and also support
for regular media for like MP4s
and MP3s.
And there's also a dependency
here on the UI library,
which brings in
SimpleExoPlayerView, which
is a minimal but
customizable player that you
can put in your app.
So once we've added
the dependency,
the next step is to
add some code snippets
to your activity, which will
create a player and use it.
So we have this
ExoPlayer factory,
which has several methods for
creating player instances.
And this is the
easiest to use one.
It takes a context
and a track selector.
And for this simple
use case we can
use the
DefaultTrackSelector which
has sensible defaults for almost
everything you'd want to do.
Once we've created the
player, the next step
is to drop a view
into your app's layout
and then bind it to the player
by calling the setPlayer
method.
Now most importantly, we need to
tell the player exactly what we
want to play.
And for this we're going
to use a MediaSource.
In ExoPlayer, everything that
you can play is a MediaSource.
It's responsible for
loading the media
and providing it to the player.
So we're going to create an
ExtractorMediaSource, which
has support for regular
media files like MP4s, MP3s,
and Matroska files and so on.
So you pass that to
the prepare method.
And then we call
setPlayWhenReady
to tell the player that as
soon as buffering is completed
and playback can begin,
then playback should start.
And finally it's very
important that you release
the player when
playback is complete
because the player holds
system resources like codecs
and it uses memory for buffers.
So these code snippets
would generally
go in activity lifecycle
methods in your app.
So this is a video
of what you got.
I've got a nice video of
the skyline of London.
And you can see there
that it had basic playback
controls like play and
pause button and a seek bar.
So if you'd like
to try this out,
there's a codelab being
published as part of I/O, which
you can go and try out.
And there's also
a developer guide
on our project page, which will
walk you through these steps.
So as I mentioned,
everything that you can play
is a media source.
And it's responsible for
loading media for the player.
And in that example we
used ExtractorMediaSource,
but there are actually
other more advanced media
sources available.
So you may have
heard of DASH, which
is a specification
for streaming which
allows for adaptation
between qualities
to handle varying
network conditions.
And we provide DASHMediaSource
for support for DASH.
We also have a HLS media
source for supporting
HTTP live streaming and a media
source for SmoothStreaming.
And with our recent
v2 release, we've
also added a new category
of MediaSources which
are designed for composition.
And by composition we
mean joining together
other media sources.
Why would we want to do this?
Well I'll go through an example.
So let's say we've got a
video that we want to play
and also some subtitles,
which are in a separate file,
an SRT file.
In that case, we can create
an ExtractorMediaSource
to load the video, a single
sample media source, which
is going to load the SRT file.
And then we're going to play the
subtitles alongside the video.
Now you could try
and do this yourself
by looking at the
player position
and synchronizing the playback
position with the subtitles
that you're showing.
But this is actually quite
difficult to do in general.
It's much easier to use
a MergingMediaSource.
And the MergingMediaSource
just takes the video
you want to play
and the subtitles
and handles everything for you.
So it will handle
the synchronization.
And then they'll be
shown in the player.
Another time you'd use
composition is for playlists.
So in this case, say you
have an album of MP3s
that you want to
play back to back.
You could try and
do this yourself
by playing the first stream
and then swapping out
the source for the next one.
But that's not going to be
great because the player is
going to buffer when
you swap out the source.
So we've added a
ConcatenatingMediaSource,
which takes a list
of sources that you
want to combine together
and then plays them
back to back with a
consistent buffering policy.
So if you tell the player to
have three seconds of media
buffered at all
times, then it will
ensure that that is the
case even across transitions
from one source to the next.
And this also supports
gapless playback metadata.
So you can play the album
of MP3s with completely
seamless playback.
And also composition
is very flexible.
So we can combine those
two examples that we saw.
So we concatenate a video
with the merged source
that we created earlier
that had subtitles.
And if you do that, this is
what you're going to get.
So the first video plays.
And then when the
first video completes,
we get a seamless transition
to the next video.
And you can see the
subtitles are coming up
as we'd expect there.
So this is great.
We can play these
compositions of media.
So we implemented this.
And then we thought,
hold on a moment.
We've got this seekTo
method on the player.
But now we've got playlists
that we want to play back
that have multiple sources.
And a timestamp is not
really enough information
to know where you want
to seek to anymore.
So we thought about
this, and we thought
about other types of media
sources you might want to play,
like live media sources.
And we realized that we really
need a way to expose to the app
the structure of
the media source
and what media is available.
So to solve the issue
of needing to know which
source you want to seek
into, we added a parameter
that tells the player
which of the source
is in the playlist
you want to seek to.
And then we thought,
we're going to need
a description of
the media available.
So we added a new data
structure called a timeline.
And a timeline basically
is a representation
of all the media that is
available in a media source.
And it consists of
a list of windows.
Each of those
windows corresponds
to one item in a playlist.
And it describes which
parts of the media
you can seek to at
any given moment.
So I'm going to show
an example of this
to make it a bit clearer.
So let's imagine we've
got a single source where
you can seek anywhere.
The red line here
represents one window.
The dot at the left
hand side represents
the default start position for
this media source is at zero.
So when the player
reaches the source,
if it's in a concatenation,
then it will go to time zero.
And the window
extends all the way
to the duration of
the media source.
A more interesting case is if
you concatenate two sources
together.
And in this case, you
end up with a timeline
that has two windows.
And as you can see,
for both windows
the start position is at the
beginning of that source.
What about if we have
a live media source?
Well in this case, the
timeline is actually dynamic.
So as the live event
progresses, more media
is becoming available
in the window.
And you can see that
the default position
is tracking the live edge.
And then when the
live event completes,
the default position snaps
back to the beginning
so that this becomes
a regular stream where
playback begins at
the beginning and you
can seek to any position.
And we can build on
top of this to have
concatenations of regular
streams and live streams.
And this works in
the way you'd expect.
So when you concatenate
sources, you
end up with a time
line that consists
of the concatenation
of the windows
of those individual sources.
So you'll see this
timeline exposed
in ExoPlayer's top level API.
You can get the
current timeline.
You can pass in a window index
when you seek the player.
So you can say please seek to
the second item in the playlist
at a particular offset.
And you can inspect
details about these windows
like where the window
starts and how long it is.
Now back over to Ollie to
talk a bit about the internals
of the players.
OLIVER WOODMAN:
So as Andrew says,
we're now going to dive in
a bit deeper to ExoPlayer,
and really talk about
what happens internally
during a playback.
And the reason that
we're going to do this
is that after we've
talked about some
of the internal
components, we're
then going to go and talk about
how we might customize those
to very fine tune the player
to your specific use case.
So here we have an
ExoPlayer and it's just
received its MediaSource
that it's going to play back.
So what are the important
internal components?
Well the first
important component
that we should
mention are renderers.
A renderer is
responsible for rendering
a single component of media.
So a VideoRenderer will
decode and display just video.
And an AudioRenderer similarly
will decode and output
just audio.
And a real ExoPlayer
instance will
have additional renderers for
things like text and metadata
as well.
But we're going to omit
those from this diagram just
for simplicity.
Another component that is
important is a TrackSelector.
A media source may
actually expose
multiple tracks that could
be played back by the player.
Particularly if you have a
DASH or HLS adaptive playback,
the MediaSource may actually
expose multiple video streams
at different resolutions, and
maybe multiple audio languages
as well.
And its the job of
the TrackSelector
to select the subset
of those tracks
that should be buffered
and played by the player.
The last component that we need
to talk about is a LoadControl.
A LoadControl
actually has two jobs.
Its first job is to
tell the MediaSource
whether it should be buffering
at this point in time.
And this is indicated
in this diagram
by the green dots on
the left hand side.
So since we haven't
started playback yet,
we don't have anything buffered.
And therefore it's green to
represent that a MediaSource
should be buffering.
Its second job is to tell
the player when playback
is actually allowed to start.
This is represented by
the right hand side dot.
And because we don't
have any media yet,
it's obviously too soon to start
playback and therefore is red.
One of the components that we
should mention are DataSources.
MediaSources use DataSources
to load the actual media
that I'm going to provide
to the player for playback.
So I've kind of given you
some major components.
But let's talk a
little bit about how
these components actually
interact during a playback.
Well we haven't
buffered anything yet,
and LoadControl is
telling the MediaSource
that it should be buffering.
And so the MediaSource is
going to start loading data
through its DataSource.
And after it's
loaded enough media,
probably not very much, just a
header for a normal media file,
the MediaSource is going
to be able to work out
what tracks it can actually
expose to the player.
And it does this by exposing
something called TrackGroups.
Now we know the TrackSelector
is the thing that's
going to choose which of
the tracks to actually play.
But the TrackSelector
needs something else.
And the reason it
needs something else
is that different devices
have different capabilities.
And in particular
the VideoRenderer
may only be able to decode up
to a particular resolution.
And so even if the MediaSource
exposes a 4K video stream,
if you're on a low
end device, it's
not going to make sense
for the TrackSelector
to actually choose that stream.
And the way we represent
these kind of capabilities
in the player is we have each
renderer expose something
called a
RendererCapabilities object
that describes specifically what
it's actually able to handle.
So what happens next
is that the TrackGroups
and the RendererCapabilities
are fed into the TrackSelector.
The TrackSelector
does its magic.
It produces a selection.
And that selection goes
back to the MediaSource.
At this point the
MediaSource knows
what it's going to
buffer, because it
knows what the
track selection is,
and so it allocates
some buffers.
Of course we still
haven't actually
loaded any useful
media for playback.
The LoadControl is still
telling the MediaSource to load.
And therefore the MediaSource
continues to load data
and it starts to
fill its buffers.
And what you can see
here is that as soon
as these buffers
start to get full,
the renderers actually start
consuming from those buffers
and feeding that media data
through their decoders,
getting ready for playback.
So at this point we
have some media buffers.
The renderers have
decoded a bit of media,
so they're kind of
primed and ready to go.
And so LoadControl
may at this point
actually start the playback.
So that little red
circle has gone green.
And of course the MediaSource
is continuing to buffer.
And at this point we've actually
buffered quite a lot of media.
So these buffers on the left
hand side are quite full.
Of course we don't want to
buffer arbitrarily far ahead.
So the LoadControl may stop
buffering at this point.
Because playbacks
continuing, the renderers
are still consuming.
And therefore these buffers
are draining back down
to a lower level.
Of course we don't want
the buffers to run out,
so the LoadControl might
toggle buffering on again.
And so you see this
pattern emerging
of data being pulled
through the DataSource
into MediaSource and
out to the renderers.
One additional complexity
to keep in mind
when you're thinking about
this is, as Andrew said,
a MediaSource can actually be a
concatenation of, for example,
different videos.
And those videos may have a
different selection of tracks
available.
And so as this
process is continuing,
you may actually get
additional track selections
taking place at the same time.
And so here we have the
playback continuing.
The buffers are filling
up and draining down.
And you see this pattern of
data being intermittently read
through the DataSource
and continuously consumed
by the renderers.
So now we know a bit about how
the important components work
during a playback.
Let's talk a little bit
about how we might customize
those internal behaviors.
So here is code snippet
Andrew showed you earlier.
We're creating an ExoPlayer
with ExoPlayerFactory.
But there are actually
more complicated methods
for creating an ExoPlayer
This is one of them.
And you can see that what we're
injecting into this player
instance are exactly the
components that we've just
been talking about-- so the
renderers, a TrackSelector,
and a LoadControl.
And here we're just inserting
default implementations.
So let's look at how we might
fine tune the player by pulling
one of those out.
So we'll look at
the LoadControl.
And here we're still using
the default implementation.
But we can actually pass some
variables into the constructor
to manipulate its behavior.
So this default
LoadControl is saying
that it wants between 15 and
30 seconds in the buffer,
and it wants to
start playback when
there's 2.5 seconds buffered.
So what does that
looks like in terms
of wall clock time
versus duration
of media in the buffer?
Well the buffer starts to fill.
And at 2.5 seconds we
allow playback to start,
as indicated by the
little orange dot.
And the LoadControl allows
buffering to continue up
until 30 seconds.
Buffering will then be
turned off for a while.
And the MediaSource
buffers would drain down
to 15 seconds, which
is the lower limit.
And buffering would
then turn on again.
And so you get this
kind of sawtooth pattern
in terms of buffering behavior.
So at this point it's
probably quite clear
that you can start to really
influence this behavior.
So you could change this
number from 15 to 25
if you're not comfortable
with allowing a buffer
to drain that low.
And because we understand how
default LoadControl works,
we can show the new graph.
So here the buffer is kept
more full at all points
during the playback.
And buffering is toggled on
and off far more frequently.
We could also
decide we might want
to be more conservative when
we allow playback to start.
So we bump up the value from
2.5 seconds to 10 seconds.
And again we can
understand the difference
in terms of this graph.
We can now take our
modified default LoadControl
and inject it back
into the player.
So what if
LoadControl just isn't
flexible enough for the actual
buffering policy that you want?
Well you can go further
and you can just
implement your own
LoadControl from scratch.
So one of the
methods that you have
to implement if you do this is
called shouldContinueLoading.
It returns a boolean.
It's polled during playback.
And this is exactly
the method that's
actually controlling whether
the MediaSource buffers or not.
And you could implement all
kinds of behaviors and logics
in your own implementation.
You can do similar things with
the TrackSelector as well.
So in this case, we can
actually get some parameters,
and we can start manipulating
the way the default
TrackSelector actually
chooses its tracks.
So here we're limiting the
video tracks to SD, so 480p.
And you might want to do this
if you know that your user is
on a metered mobile connection.
And even if they have
really great bandwidth,
you probably don't want to use
all of their data very quickly.
So you might want to
keep a cap on the quality
that you deliver.
Similarly if you know
that your user is German,
you might select a preferred
audio language for the case
where there are multiple
audio tracks exposed
by the MediaSource.
And you can certainly
modify parameters back
on the selector to actually
activate this new behavior.
Again if the default
implementation of TrackSelector
isn't suitable, you can go
a step further and implement
your own TrackSelector.
One of the methods
you need to implement
if you do this is selectTracks.
And hopefully you can map
the signature of this method
back to the diagram
we saw earlier.
It's receiving the
capabilities from the renderers
and the TrackGroups
from the MediaSource,
and it's generating a selection.
And of course the same
tricks can be applied
for the renderers as well.
Implementing your own
VideoRenderer from scratch
is a pretty advanced
customization,
but you could do it if
you really wanted to
and you kind of have a good
handle on exactly what you
have to do to achieve that.
And you could extend
default RenderersFactory,
override the
buildVideoRenderers method,
and actually inject your own
VideoRenderer into the player
instead of the default that
would normally be created.
ANDREW LEWIS: OK, great.
So hopefully you can
see a pattern emerging
in each of the examples
of customization
that Ollie talked about.
So the first step
was establishing
which component in the
player we need to customize,
whether it's the TrackSelector
or the LoadControl.
Then you look at the
API for that component
and see if there's a way to
customize its behavior using,
say, a different parameter,
as we did with LoadControl.
If that's not a
possibility, then you
might be able to
extend or actually
implement your own version of
this component from scratch.
So I'm just going to do one
more example of customization
on the MediaSource
side this time.
So imagine that we need
to send an authorization
header with each HTTP request
that a MediaSource makes.
Well, we know that
we are passing
in a HttpDataSourceFactory.
And this has a convenient method
to get the default request
properties.
And by getting the default
request properties,
we can actually set a new header
to set the authorization header
on the HTTP request.
And once you've done that, you
pass the httpDataSourceFactory
into the MediaSource.
And that header will appear
on all requests that it makes.
As another example,
let's say that you
know that users are going to
rewind videos quite a lot,
so you want to add a cache
in so that the player doesn't
repeatedly load the same
media off the network.
ExoPlayer has a simple
cache which you can use.
And in this example
I'm posting in a
LeastRecentlyUsedCacheEvictor.
So the way this is
going to work is
the cache has a maximum size.
But if the media is
longer than that, then
when the media
finishes, if they've
watched the media
all the way through,
then the cache
will actually have
started to evict the
very beginning of it.
So this cache gets passed
into a CacheDataSourceFactory.
And it also needs to take
a normal DataSource which
is used if there's a cache miss
and also to populate the cache.
And then you pass the
CacheDataSourceFactory
to the ExtractorMediaSource.
So hopefully to make this
a little bit clearer,
let's see how it fits
in with the player
architecture we saw earlier.
This cache is actually going
to sit between the MediaSource
and the HttpDataSource.
And when the MediaSource
requests data,
it's first going to
look it up in the cache.
If there's a cache miss, then
it's going to go to the network
and use the HttpDataSource.
Then when that
request is satisfied,
it's going to come back
and fill in the cache
so that next time the
MediaSource requests
the same chunk, then hopefully
it's going to be in the cache.
So we talked about how
the kind of extreme case
of customization is
providing a MediaSource
or whatever that you've
implemented yourself.
So I'm going to go through
an example of doing that.
Let's say that you've
got an app where you're
showing some
content, but now you
want to monetize that content
by showing ads alongside it.
Let's have a think about
what the timeline is going
to look like in this case.
Well, it may be very simple.
In this example on
the screen there's
just one ad at the
beginning, a pre-roll ad.
Or it may be more complicated.
So in this case
there's a pre-roll ad
on a mid-roll ad
and a post-roll ad.
And they kind of
split up the content.
So at first glance
you might think
this is a place where we could
use ConcatenatingMediaSource.
But unfortunately normally
when you're loading ads,
you can't actually commit
to a particular ad URI
until the time when
you're about to play it.
It's not the case that we have
a list of exactly what ads
we're going to play upfront.
So let's see what would
happen if we tried
to use just one player with
conventional MediaSources
to play these ads.
So at the beginning of
playback, we got the URI
for the first ad, and
then we can play it.
But then we know that we
need to play the content.
So the player is
actually going to buffer
when we tell it that we want
to play the content instead.
Then the content will
play back and the user
is going to see buffering again.
Then the ad, more
buffering, and I
guess you're saying how
this is going to work.
There's a lot of buffering.
And this is not a
good user experience.
So one way that people
try to work around this
is they will try
and use two players.
And the idea is
that one player is
going to play what's on
the screen at the moment
while the other player is in the
background buffering whatever
is coming up next.
So as soon as the
ad URI arrives,
you can populate the
background player
and hopefully get
some data buffered
before playback begins.
And in this case,
the playback will
switch in between the
ad and the content.
But this solution also
has its drawbacks.
These two players are both going
to use up memory for buffering,
and they may even both be
using codecs at the same time.
So that's not very good.
And also this is
just very difficult
to implement correctly if
you've ever tried doing this.
So we thought about implementing
a MediaSource that's
specifically designed for ads.
And this MediaSource
is implemented
in a slightly similar way to
the concatenating media source,
except that it has these
playlists items which
are not populated.
And those are represented
by the question marks.
Those are going to get
filled in with the ads
as soon as they arrive.
So let's see what
playback would look
like with this
hypothetical MediaSource.
Playback begins and
we get the first ad.
Then the content plays.
Hopefully we get the next
ad a little bit early.
And that placeholder is
filled in in the timeline.
And if this works
well, then the user
is actually not going to see
any buffering during playback.
So as a real practical
example of this,
Google provides the
InteractiveMediaAds SDK.
You may have heard of it.
And we're using that for loading
ads in this ImaAdsMediaSource.
And as you can see,
the area kind of
highlights when the
ad is loaded from IMA.
And the media source
is wrapping IMA,
so the player doesn't need to
worry about any details of how
ads are actually loaded.
And in this timeline you
get seamless transitions
between content and ads.
So we actually pushed this
to our development branch
today if you want
an early preview,
if you want to try inserting
ads in your content.
It's very easy to use.
So you take your
content MediaSource
and you pass it
into the construct
of an ImaAdsMediaSource along
with an adTagUri which defines
what ad playlists to load.
And it also takes
an OverlayViewGroup
which interactive
media ads will use
to show any ad user interface
on top of your player
like a skip button, for example.
Here's what you get
if you try doing this.
So you can see the
pre-roll ad is playing.
And then when the
ad finishes we get
a pretty seamless
transition between the ad
into the content.
And you can see that our
playback controls have support
for showing little ad
markers so the user can
see where the mid-roll ads are.
And during this
playback, there's
a consistent buffering policy
being applied at all times.
Now back to Ollie to talk
about some of our future plans.
OLIVER WOODMAN: So
before we leave you,
I just want to say a little
bit about the direction
in which ExoPlayer is headed.
Just to caveat this,
this is no way a promise,
and we're not going to
put timelines on anything.
But in terms of
the kind of things
that we're going to be looking
at over the next six months
to a year, we're
going to continue
to fill in the
remaining feature gaps
that we have in terms of
becoming a really complete
media playback library.
One specific thing here that
we know is causing a lot of you
problems is proper
support for offline.
So this is where you
actually download
media to playback later.
And so you can
expect us to start
building up support for offline
during the next six months
to a year.
We're also going
to continue to work
on performance enhancements.
And by that I mean things like
maintaining decoder instances
from the platform from
one playback to the next,
because releasing
and instantiating
those decoders as we do
now can be quite expensive.
Another aspect of performance
that we intend to look at
is improved adaptive track
selections for DASH and HLS
and SmoothStreaming
adaptive playbacks, and also
more advanced
buffering policies.
So the default components
that we currently
provide for performing
these tasks,
they're pretty
effective, but they're
quite simple in terms of
the policies they implement.
So we really want to start
kind of diving deeper
and doing some proper
research and kind
of fine tuning these to
deliver better performance out
of the box.
And finally we know that the
ExoPlayer API is very large
and that it can be daunting
to get started with
and to figure out exactly where
you need to dive in if you
want to customize something.
So we're going to work on some
better documentation as well,
probably starting
with documenting
some of the internal
components that the player is
using, as we described earlier.
In terms of what you can
do next with ExoPlayer
whilst you're here, we
have office hours tomorrow
over in the office hours
box at 9:30 in the morning.
So if you have any questions for
us, then please do come along
and we'll be more than happy to
have a chat and to answer them.
If you want to go and
check out our source codes,
the GitHub repository is public
and you can go and have a look.
And we also have
a home page, which
includes the developer guides
that will help you get started.
And it also has various
piece of documentation
such as supported formats.
And with that, I'd like to
just thank you all for coming.
We unfortunately don't have
time for questions now,
but we will probably just
down in the corner afterwards.
And as I said, if
you do have questions
that we can't answer
now, please do
you come along tomorrow
morning and we'd
be happy to answer them.
So thank you very
much for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]